this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbusters
summer from a director at the height of
his powers the biggest movie star on the
planet and an untapped source material
with an original premise comes a
cinematic faceplant into a steaming pile
of horseshit
Will Smith passed on the matrix for this
you guys sorry Wicky Wicky wild wild
west Geddy uh for the best movie where a
former runaway slave turned Cowboy teams
up with an upper-crust white guy who
invents a gun that pops out of a sleeve
as they face off against a flamboyant
wealthy racist southern villain okay
second best but what's easily the best
sci-fi comedy of the 90s about a mad
scientist in the Old West whose base
camp is a hi-tech train oh forgot about
that one
okay well it's deadly the best Barry
Sonnenfeld directed sci-fi comedy buddy
movie where Will Smith teams up with an
older white co-star to play government
agents that ends with him fighting a
giant arthropod that came out on July
4th weekend I'll come on beat Jim West
and harmless Gordon the serious straight
shooter and the wacky sidekick but they
never settle on which one is which Will
Smith shines as a guy in a cowboy
stripper outfit who gives up on his
accent halfway through the movie that'd
be an awful career decision down
we'd be getting a lot faster if you
weren't dragging that thing around and
kevin kline shines as the guy standing
next to Will Smith yep there is there is
again Kevin who are nailing this they'll
team up to take down the evil dr.
loveless a racist fascist mad scientist
trying to overthrow the government but
that won't stop our heroes from really
taking him to task for being disabled
well I can see where it'd be difficult
for a man of your stature to keep in
touch with even half the people you know
crazy beards out your height see them
actually I was thinking maybe I'd stuff
you a little half an ass in one of these
cannons and fertilize the landscape with
you that's all you're gonna roast him
for when a fella comes back from the
dead I find that an occasion to stand up
we got a lovely little half a jail cell
picked out for you what it will cheer
kill your father or something I guess
when it comes right down to it you just
can't beat a good old-fashioned pair of
legs he wants to bring back slavery
gonna damn him for that at all Oh you
know beautiful women they encourage you
one minute got the legs out from under
you the next nope just the leg jokes
okay cool I'm just as tough as you are
and also there's a lady so impetuous I
know that seems tacked on but so she
he's so courageous oh so graceful
returned to a time when America had to
confront the most shameful issue of
American history boners because this
movie is so horny that when it's not
showing you its horny gadgets touching
it's constantly trying to show you its
dick
it's deep it's diminishing returns on
all the lazy sex jokes
by the way boobies look great tonight
nice and perky she's a breast of fresh
air
who wrote this like creepy uncle I have
them square in my sight sire as do our
ammunition the curvature of her buttocks
and the swell of that magnificent bosom
so full so sensuous max - she's a breath
of fresh ass why is this movie so horny
so saddle up for a film so disappointing
that it's only legacy is five Razzies
one great Kevin Smith anecdote so anyway
I'm going to meet John Peters he said I
got some directives for you he's got to
fight a giant spider in the third act
and the accidental career resurgence of
Keanu Reeves but hey at least it's the
best kevin kline movie where he
impersonates the president really the
best sci-fi and Western with an
anachronistic theme song gotta be
kidding me
the best movie where Will Smith fights a
redneck in the engine room of a
mechanical spider I learn neck from a
[ __ ] okay this doesn't happen in
pursuit of happiness or the orc cop
movie know who nailed it
starring ah hee ha done an Internet
inspect her gadgets damsel out of
distress shouldn't this be a spider-man
villain DJ ear horn
remember when you were partying I study
the blades and Will Smith trying to make
a line funnier by yelling it
Gordon Gordon Gordon
that is not how jokes work the not very
good the bad and the somehow even worse
you know there's a little part of me
wishes John Peters didn't get to force
the giant spider into this movie and had
to put it in one of his others like a
star is born thank you for watching this
video but did you know we also make
other videos with just one click you
could be watching one of those videos
now awful waffleh waffleh waffleh feel
awful awful awful awful awful waffle I
love the buttery biscuit bays smokin